hello and welcome everyone this is
active inference guest stream number
55.1 it's August 30th 2023
today we are going to have a
presentation followed by a discussion
on geometric constraints on human brain
function by James Payne and Alex fornito
thank you again for joining
really looking forward to the
presentation and the discussion so
please off to YouTube to introduce
yourself and continue however you like
thank you
oh thanks very much Daniel uh my name is
Alex Bonita I'm based in the school of
psychological sciences and internal
Institute for brain and mental health at
Monash University and we had James pen
who is a research fellow working in the
team and so the idea today was that we
were going to talk a little bit about
this work I'll begin by providing a bit
of a
historical and theoretical background
and then James will take over and jump
into the specifics of what we did and
what we found
uh
we're assuming some basic understanding
of Neuroscience and some elements of
human brain Imaging and we'll go through
a little bit of maths but hopefully
it'll be enough to give a picture and if
there's any questions about it
afterwards we'll be happy to try and
answer them
so a key motivating factor for this work
is really trying to understand how the
structure or anatomy of the brain
constrains its function and if you look
at a diverse range of systems found
throughout nature uh we know that the
structure of the system constrained its
Dynamic so for example the the shape of
a racing car will influence its
aerodynamics and how fast it can go the
folding patterns of a protein will
influence the other proteins that it can
interact with and quite have quite large
effects so here for example we've got an
example of the hemoglobin protein in a
healthy person and someone with sickle
cell anemia and this change in the
geometry of the protein leads to a
20-year difference in life expectancy
and here we've got the molecular
structures of diamond and graphite so
both of these materials are made of the
same atoms they're all purely carbon
atoms it's just the bonds between them
that are different and that difference
is sufficient to create quite
A variation in the properties of the
material so Diamond being one of the
hardest substances on Earth and valued
at somewhere between 12 to 90 million
dollars per kilo whereas graphite is one
of the most brittle and only cost you
about twenty dollars per kilo and so
this is essentially the reason why we
don't propose to people with h2b pencil
we used diamond rings instead
now the brain is no different we think
Anatomy constraints function but there
has been a long-standing debate about
the specific properties that are the
most relevant and how we should best
conceptualize them and this can be
traced back to the days of ramonica Hall
and Camilla Golgi two people considered
to be some of the founding fathers of
modern Neuroscience Golgi developed a
technique for staining neurons that
allowed you to visualize their structure
under the microscope and kahal really
perfected that technique and studied the
nervous system in extensive detail and
really laid down the foundations for we
think about the anatomy of the brain to
this state
now both of these men were recognized
for their efforts in 1906 with a Nobel
Prize but even at the award ceremony
when giving their lectures they were in
bitter disagreement so if you actually
look at the recordings of their lectures
kahal says we applied golgi's method in
our observations revealed in my opinion
the terminal arrangement of the nerve
fibers nerve elements possess reciprocal
relationships in contiguity but not in
continuity so here is saying that cells
are fundamentally discrete elements
separated in physical space and that
there's a a gap between them at the
synapse the synaptic clip and that's and
signaling occurs through this Gap
OG on the other hand didn't agree he
said while I admire the Brilliance of
the doctrine which is a worthy product
of the high intellect of my illustria
Spanish colleague I cannot agree with
him on some points of an anatomical
nature which are for the theory of
fundamental importance I found myself
unable to follow the current of opinion
because I was confronted by one concrete
anatomical fact
this was the existence of the formation
which I have called the diffuse nerve
Network
and so for golgiene all the cells were
continuous they form one continuous
Network there was no point of separation
between them and signaling occurred
through this continuous Network
now ultimately
uh the growing body of evidence and you
can see it in golgi's statements was
starting to favor kahal's model but
really it was only resolved in the 1940s
with the Advent of electron microscopy
where people could actually resolve
synapses and saw that they were
spatially disjoint
and this ultimately established the
neuron Doctrine as the fundamental
theory about how the nervous system is
organized at a cellular level
and this basic idea that we can divide
the brain up into discrete units was
then carried through to different scales
most famously by corbinian brodman who
developed a persolation of the context
based on a site of architectonic grounds
his idea was that different parts of the
cortex have different cellular
properties and so they Define these
discrete areas that are functionally
specialized in in some way
uh and certainly this has been a very
influential idea in Neuroscience ever
since but around the same time in fact a
couple of years earlier the neurologist
Alfred Campbell published his own signal
architectonic map and he agreed that you
could identify discrete boundaries
largely in primary zones but then in the
cortex in between there was a lot more
difficult to find sharp outlines or
boundaries and he suggested that
actually the changes were more gradual
or continuous in nature
boardman's view became more popular and
certainly became sort of the dominant
theory in neuroscience
even though subsequent attempts to try
to replicate it were different and so
different anatomists would parsolate the
brain in different ways using different
boundaries and so on
but nonetheless this kind of uh
congruence between the discrete model of
kahal and discrete model of broadman
eventually led to the idea that you know
essentially we can think about the brain
as a multi-scale network we're at the
cellular level we can identify
discrete cells that are connected by
synapses then we can scale up at the
population level the mesoscope mesoscale
resolution and identify our population
of cells are linked by bundles of exons
and then all the way through to the
macro scales which is what you sort of
see when you look at one of Rodman's
Maps you have these broad roughly
sub-architectonic areas connected by
white matter bundles
and in the last two or so decades we've
had the measurement techniques for
characterizing these networks on a vast
scale and there's been a pretty well
established pipeline for mapping these
networks so the basic idea is that we
have the brain we Define we divide it up
into these discrete areas and they act
as our Network nodes and then for every
pair of nodes we measure some aspect of
structural or functional connectivity
between them functional connectivity
being some aspect of coupling in
activity
and then we can represent that in the
form of a connectivity Matrix so each
row and column represents a different
region and each element tells you about
the type and strength of connectivity
between areas and that coin can
equivalently be represented as a graph
and then with that graph representation
we can apply all sorts of different
analytic tools to understand different
aspects about how the network is is
connected and organized
and this is this basic approach has been
used quite extensively to understand how
the underlying anatomical properties of
the network constrain function this is
one of my favorite examples this was a
study of two different worms C elegans
and pacificus uh both of their nervous
systems and the head have been mapped at
the level of each cell and synapse and
they're actually identical so they've
got the same type of cells the same
number of cells it's just the
connectivity between them that's
different and that's what you see in
this network projection here that the
topology of the Network's different in
this study they showed that changes in
the connectivity of just two Hub neurons
were sufficient to
elicit a difference in the behavior of
the animals such that pacificus is a
predator of c elegans and here you can
see pacificus eating poor C elegans for
lunch
now we can't lock humans up in a room
and see who eats who and try to
understand how their Anatomy constraints
function in that way but we can do
things like use MRI to measure
anatomical connectivity and functional
connectivity and correlate the two and
it's pretty consistent in finding that
we generally find there is a correlation
between them
uh we can run computational models where
we have a structural Network we simulate
the activity then we apply say a lesion
to that Network and look at the effects
on the activity and we can show for
example that if you leisure in a hub
area you have quite a dramatic impact on
brain function compared to a theologian
a more weakly connected non-hub area
or we could use clinical studies we
could look at cases where there are
naturally arising lesions through a
stroke or some other form of brain
damage and we can understand the
functional impairments that result so
for example in this case uh people with
lesions to certain types of Hub areas
with diffuse connectivity showed much
more generalized cognitive impairments
than people with lesions to areas with
more specific patterns of connectivity
so this is great this has been really
informative and great for understanding
the role of individual brain regions or
Connections in brain function but it
doesn't really give us a coherent
unified perspective about how Dynamics
emerge from the underlying structure
it's all a little bit piecemeal
now if we wanna
develop such a coherent understanding we
can draw some inspiration from different
uh
the physics and Engineering where
typically the structural
constraints on the Dynamics of a system
are studied by understanding the eigen
modes of the system
now the arguments of a system are found
by solving an eigenvalue problem such as
this one so an eigenvector we can think
of as something that we measure about a
system that doesn't change its direction
if it's subjected to some kind of
transformation so if that's the case
then this equality holds so the idea
here is that PSI is our Vector something
we measure about the system subjected to
some transformation L and uh if PSI is
an eigenvector then the transformed
eigenvector is equal to the eigenvector
just scaled by some back value so we can
the transformation can scale the vector
but it doesn't change its direction
and so if that's the case then this
scaling Factor Lambda is what we call an
eigenvalue and PSI is an eigenvector
this kind of equation is applied to a
lot of different systems a lot of
different contexts but when we're
studying the eigen modes of a system
typically
our L term here is is an operator called
the laplacian operator which essentially
describes how smoothly some kind of
structural property of the system varies
through an appropriate spatial embedding
so I'll come back a little bit to what
that means because we can make different
choices for what we use in L and that
determines the specific anatomical
properties that we prioritize
but for now I just want to emphasize
that a e property of these eigenvectors
is that they're orthogonal and so that
we then we can use them as an
a basis set for reconstructing different
activity patterns that we might see in
the network
so I guess the most famous example of a
basis set that many people will be
familiar with is a Fourier set so for
example here we have some
one-dimensional signal and we can
decompose that signal as a weighted sum
of sine and cosine functions of varying
frequencies so here you've got the the
different functions different
frequencies and here you've got some
weighting factors and we can reconstruct
this signal as a weighted sum of these
functions
in a similar way we can extract our
eigen modes of the brain based on some
particular anatomical property
and we end up with these spatial
patterns here that are organized again
in terms of spatial frequency or the
wavelength of fluctuation so here you
can see we've got a very low frequency
fluctuation moving from Back to Front
top to bottom media lateral and then as
you move up you get these more high
frequency fluctuations
and so then we can use these patterns to
reconstruct any spatial map that we
observe on the brain so it could be a
map of brain activity recorded during a
particular task it could be say a map of
cortical thickness variations or gray
matter volume variations uh it's
sufficiently General to allow you to
reconstruct any type of map and so we
can do that just as a weighted sum so
here y represents our map and then we
represent that as a weighted sum of our
modes with the a coefficients
representing the weights
and people oh sorry
um I should emphasize that that
explanation can be a little bit abstract
for people who aren't familiar with
eigen modes and it is always a bit of a
challenge to get an intuition and so you
can do what one of the people in the
team did and and ask chat GPT to explain
eigenmodes to a 10 year old and it turns
out that it does a pretty good job I was
quite happy with this explanation so I
thought I'd share it
so I'll check gbt says of course let's
imagine we have a wobbly jiggly ball of
jelly when you poke it it Wiggles and
shakes right now imagine if you poke the
jelly in different spots or with
different amounts of force each time you
poke it differently the jelly Wiggles
and shakes in a different way eigen
modes are like those different ways the
jelly Wiggles and shakes when you poke
it
so essentially seeing this video here
the jelly is poke and it wobbles in a
particular way if you poke the jelly in
a different spot or with a different
amount of force you'll trigger a
different pattern of vibration and so
commonly eigen modes are used in the
context of systems that vibrate and the
idea is these eigen modes correspond to
Preferred patterns of vibration when the
system is perturbed and those preferred
plans are just dictated by the
structural properties of that system we
can we can extend it more generally and
think about it more as how a system
responds to any type of excitation and
how an excitation spreads through some
connected system and the eigen modes
correspond to the preferred patterns of
excitation again determined by the
physical properties of the system
so
naturally given everything we've been
talking about and these ideas that the
brain is a multi-scale network we need
to make a choice about how we Define
alloplastian what specific anatomical
properties are we going to extract our
eigen modes from and so Natural Choice
would be to extract them from brain
connectivity right and we can do this
quite in a reasonably straightforward
way we get some map of the connections
in the brain we map connectivity between
every pair of nodes after we apply some
discretization we Define our discrete
nodes we map every pair of connections
we represent that in the form of a
matrix and then we extract this quantity
here it's called the graph laplacian
it's the details are not so important
but that's essentially our L operator
here and it describes how smoothly
connectivity varies as we move from node
to node in the network
and when we do that we can several
Studies have shown that you can use the
eigen modes extracted from this graph
laplacian to reconstruct kind of classic
functional networks that you record with
functional MRI
we can reconstruct different patterns of
functional connectivity between Pairs of
areas like you can use it to reconstruct
different EG signals and people have
even shown that you can make predictions
about the pattern of neurodegeneration
that you see in different forms of
dementia
so this has been really fantastic
important work and a really important
proof of principle that this eigenmode
framework can be used to understand how
the structure of the system constrains
its Dynamics and in each case the
interpretation is that these dynamical
patterns that we see with fmri or EEG or
so on are reflecting excitations of
these underlying eigen modes or the
resonant modes of the anatomy of the
brain
this V very much aligns with what we
would think of as a classical view of a
brain organization that I've just been
discussing so following from kahal and
broadman's work the idea is that lots of
different scales we can divide the brain
up into discrete areas they're connected
in some way and it's the signaling along
these connections between these discrete
areas that drives activity
but there are reasons to think that
particularly at coarser scale so we know
at the fundamental cellular scale the
network is discrete but at coarser
Scales perhaps a different set of
approximations might be useful
so if you look at dense reconstructions
of neuronal tissue so this is say with
electron microscopy
you find that cortical tissue is
extremely dented it's like a really rich
thick forest of cells and their
processes
and as we've talked about the there's
been a lot of debate about where you can
actually draw boundaries between
discrete areas and how valid that and
reliable that is outside some kind of
classic examples saying in primary
cortex
and if you look more deeply at the
cellular organization of specific
regions here on the left we've got the
cellular organization and on the right
we've got a myelin stain you see you get
these deep penetrating fibers that are
coming in from the white matter this is
what this kind of classic graph approach
will pick up because we divide we Define
our nodes in the cortex and then we're
mapping the connections that pass
through the white matter
they can also say that there's a lot of
connectivity that's moving horizontally
or tangential to the geometry of the
cortex and so these horizontal
connections allow for the continuous
spread of activity so rather than
actively jumping between discrete nodes
it can actually spread as a propagating
wave
[Music]
and you know just to emphasize the some
of the limitations of the discrete model
uh not long after broadman's work just a
couple of decades the renowned
physiologist lorento Deno was pretty
emphatic about uh his his concerns with
the approach he said the only really
good site of architectonic pictures of
those of Campbell who let me put in
capital letters as the being the only
side of architectonist who has described
facts and only facts the German cyto
architect honest has mixed facts and
theory in such a manner that nobody can
tell where facts ends in theories begin
so again this is just emphasizing the
idea that while we might be able to
Define discrete areas at a mesoscopic or
macroscopic resolutions in some cases
especially around the borders of primary
sensory or motor areas but large swathes
of Cortex those distinctions become a
little bit blurry
so an alternative approach has emerged
out of neural field Theory so neural
field theory has been around for several
decades now
and this is a different approach to
thinking about cortical activity so uh
the basic idea is that instead of
dividing the brain into discrete
specialized areas or nodes we can treat
the cortex as a continuous shape and we
actually uninterested in trying to
capture our patterns of brain activity
propagate through that continuous shape
and so this is something that you can
see in diverse types of
electrophysiological recordings so this
for example this video is of the
Dynamics of voltage-sensitive dyes
recorded in in the mouse brain and you
can see that you observe these
propagating waves of excitation that
move continuously through the cortex
rather than jumping from region to
region as would be implied by a kind of
strongly discrete model
so a big emphasis in neural field theory
is on describing these wave-like
propagation patterns
and it's been shown in recent
theoretical work that if we accept the
wave like propagation drives neuronal
activity then really the eigen modes
that we should be extracting or
prioritizing are those that are derived
from the geometry of the brain
so our eigenvalue becomes this problem
here where this operator here is called
the LaPlace Beltrami operator and it
describes how smoothly the geometry or
the shape or the curvature of the brain
varies through space
and just to briefly explain why that's
the case here we've got the wave
equation that's used in some forms of
neural field Theory list of the
divisions that we've been focusing on
and so the basic idea is that the firing
rate of a given population of neurons B
at location R and T is given by the
afferent field of incoming population so
other populations a so we've got other
populations providing this afferent
field of activity
that determines the firing rate of B
and obviously we then need to describe
what this afferent field looks like and
that's given by this part of the
equation here
so on the left here this set of terms
describes how the field evolves through
time we're not going to focus on that
today over here which is what we're
interested in where we've got how the
field is evolving through space
and so here we can see our friend the
LaPlace Beltrami operator which
describes the geometry and here we've
got the length scale of axonal
connectivity so in this model we make a
very simple assumption about
conductivity we assume each point is
connected to its neighbors in a distance
dependent and isotropic way and that
distance dependence is roughly
exponential so the idea is that areas
nearby to a given location are will have
a strong influence and that influence
declines roughly exponentially as a
function of distance
and uh that the the speed of that decay
is given by this R term here
you can see that geometry is firmly
embedded in this equation now I should
point out this isn't something that's
just been plucked out of thin air this
is a damped wave equation that has been
used for centuries to describe wave
Dynamics in all sorts of different media
and so from that physics we know very
well that the geometry of the system
constrains the spatial properties of the
wave propagation
and you can start from first principles
of neuronal biophysics and derive this
equation
and given all that work we know that the
eigen modes of the LaPlace Beltrami
operator actually correspond to the
standing waves of the Dynamics so what
are standing waves so in this simple
like example we've got two traveling
waves here a blue and a green and as
they interact with each other you get
these patterns of constructive and
destructive interference uh represented
by this red line here that cause these
very large amplitude fluctuations that
are fixed in space right so they're not
actually traveling like the original
carrier waves they're fixed in space so
that's why they're called standing waves
and they're a nice example of resonance
so these fluctuations in the red
in the red Trace are much larger in
amplitude than the original carrier
waves so it's an example of resonance
where we're getting a larger response in
the system than the energy that we put
in
and just to convince you that this is
something real here for example we have
a pool of water a classic wave system if
you apply vibrations at a specific point
in in the pool you see these waves that
travel out they hit the opposite wall
reflect back and start to interact and
then you see these the emergence of
these standing wave patterns that are
fixed in space but show these very large
scale amplitude fluctuations
another classic example is the clubny
plate so if you arrange dust particles
on a plate and then you apply some
vibration at a particular frequency the
dust particles will settle into these uh
complex patterns uh the pattern is
determined by the specific frequency
that you apply and specifically where
you apply the vibration and the pattern
the patterns correspond to the eigen
modes of the plane and again those
patterns are determined by the physical
properties of the plate things like its
stiffness its geometry and so on
gratuitous but you can extend the idea
to three dimensions and you can actually
cause the particles to levitate again in
this case they're trapped within the
nodal lines of sound waves that are
being projected in three dimensions
and this does have real world
consequences so this is a video of the
Tacoma Narrows Bridge in the 1940s
the engineers didn't pay enough
attention to eigen modes and so on this
particular day Crosswinds hit the bridge
in just the right spots and just the
right frequencies to excite the
eigenmerge of the bridge so you
triggered these resonant responses and
create these large-scale amplitude
fluctuations that ultimately led to the
collapse of the bridge
so uh hopefully a background has kind of
Illustrated that there's sort of two
different views of thinking about uh
which anatomical Pro properties of the
brain might be more more important in
constraining Dynamics so on the one hand
we have the classical kind of connectome
centric view in which we view the cortex
as comprising discrete areas and
Dynamics are dominated by node to node
transmission
uh the connectivity between areas is
topologically complex and not
homogeneous and we very much think that
that's very important and so we
prioritize measuring that
we don't really directly account for the
spatial embedding of the network or its
geometry we can look at it secondarily
but it's not baked into the model
and because we're interested in
connectivity that means we need to
measure it so from a practical
perspective at least if you're dealing
with new Imaging data you need a T1
weighted image to measure brain anatomy
but also diffusion MRI image to be able
to measure brain connectivity
the other perspective uh which is a
geometrically informed perspective that
arises out of neural field Theory views
the cortex as a continuous sheet we're
not making distinctions between
different areas of the cortex we think
Dynamics are dominated by propagating
waves of excitation especially these
mesoscopic and macroscopic scales we
approximate connectivity between
different points of the cortex as being
being homogeneous and distance dependent
so we know that there is a strong
distance dependent in connectivity it
doesn't explain everything so some
things are missed but we know it's
certainly an important feature so then
the question is how far we can get with
this approximation
and a nice feature of this approach is
that we are directly accounting for
spatial and geometric effects the
physical properties of the brain which
are overlooked by the connectome
approach the nice practical benefit of
this approach is that because we
approximate connectivity in a simple way
we don't actually have to measure it we
can derive our basis set simply by
looking at the geometry of the brain and
surrounding it a T1 weighted scan which
is is very standard in MRI experiments
so hopefully that's set the scene for
thinking about different anatomical
constraints on the brain and which ones
we might want to prioritize I'll now
hand over to James he'll talk about how
we went about testing these different
ideas and trying to understand which
constraints might be more important for
Dynamics
all right thank you Alex sir
I'm gonna focus more on the things that
we found in the paper that we recently
published I think a lot of you have the
link for it but there's no incentive
message if you want
to rewind us for the the link so
basically we start with we're trying to
answer and test the theory on which
modes of the brain uh could best uh
describe activity measured in FMI so
we'll Begin by how do we actually
measure these modes so uh geometric
modes are based on the T1 weighted image
which is a standard Imaging tool that
people use in the field and you can
extract
a model of the cortical surface uh here
on the right and this there are robust
pipelines to do so and you can do that
on a population average sense basically
you get a group
template of the surface or you can do
that on an individual basis
uh on the other hand connector modes
need diffusion MRI and structure MRI
because you need to kind of align the
two
and then we run a cryptography pipeline
basically finding connections between
regions in the brain
and then from there you can construct a
Vertex level or even region level
connector Matrix basically
it's a matrix where each element
represents the connection of one region
or one vertex to another region or
another vertex
and
you feed these cortical surface or these
connector Matrix in the eigenvalue
problem equations that Alex has
mentioned in the previous slides
and then how do we test the performance
of these geometric and connector modes
basically we focus a lot on FMI data
so we uh
there are several open access data sets
in that are available for example the
the popular human connection project
which is uh which roughly has about 1200
participants but we focus on 255
participants who are completely
unrelated there are no Twins and no
siblings and within the human connection
project that is said we you can for each
subject uh they have what we call task
evoke data basically these are
functional activity uh whilst that that
was recorded was each participant was
performing a particular task and hcp has
a suite of seven different tasks in
within each task several several
different uh uh contrasts within it
and then we also analyze resting state
data basically State data is where the
the participant is just inside the
scanner and just not doing anything and
you just scan uh the brain activity
through time and you can construct a
functional connectivity as well over
each element of this Matrix represents
how correlated the activity is between
two regions
we also analyze data from what we call
numerable it's as I said it's an Open
Access repository of
thousands and thousands of different
maps that people have contributed and
each map was acquired with distinct
experimental uh protocols
and we talk about ten thousand of those
from your evolve uh and again uh it's a
the level of
um heterogeneity in the different tasks
uh is quite remarkable in the neurobot
so we wanted to make we wanted to
um
do our analyzes on on quite different
tasks to make sure we are capturing
something really meaningful
so just to remind uh yourselves of what
we're going to do next so basically
Alice already mentioned this to you
extract for example the spatial map say
that's the task about that and we
decomposed that into different sets of
wagon modes so these patterns could be
the geometric modes or they could be the
connective nodes and it will be weighted
by a coefficient a and the weights
represent how each mode is expressed uh
for that particular map and you can
truncate the number of modes that you
can that you want to use and then you
can reconstruct back the uh
the the data by just taking a linear sum
of
the coefficient multiplied by the
geometric or the connected modes
so what did we find by doing these
analyzes
so first I'm going to show you this how
the special Maps look like in terms of
reconstruction so on the left I'm
showing you the different tasks of
special maps and these are group average
maps for the human connection project
data set and again these are the seven
tasks for that data set
and then we ask okay how if we use about
10 modes uh how would this patient map
look like and for this result we're
focusing on the geometric modes
so the Reconstruction looks like this
from afar you they look quite they look
quite different but if you actually look
a bit closely it already captures the
kind of the large scale uh core scale
patterns that you can see from the data
for example this relational map you can
clearly see these the emergence of this
big pattern
now what happens if we incorporate more
modes into it so we increase the number
of modes to 100 and now you can see that
the Reconstruction almost uh looks like
the empirical data but there are still
subtle differences especially especially
in the more localized
activity for example here in the IRS and
if we increase it further you can see
that we can better capture those
isolated
localized patents uh just by increasing
it to 200 modes so you can see that the
modes are actually really an efficient
basis set for task give up data we do
the same for resting state data we
increase the number of modes in here and
compare the functional connectivity of
based from the empirical data and the
Reconstruction and we see the same thing
that has to increase the number of
months to 200 we can connect we can
capture the empirical data and you can
do this in a more systematic way
by calculating how well can we can
reconstruct the empirical data just by
you know taking the correlation of the
empirical and the reconstruction
in reconstructed Maps as a function of
an increasing number of modes and we see
that indeed the Reconstruction accuracy
increases as we increase the number of
modes and up to 200 we can get about you
know
80 85 to 90 accuracy which is quite
efficient given that uh we do the
analysis on a but on a cortical surface
with about thirty thousand vertices so
mathematically the maximum number of
modes available to us is about 30 000
and using 200 out of the 30 000 we can
already reconstruct the data quite uh
efficiently
and then we now
so we've shown that the modes are quite
powerful and efficient in representing
uh the data we now test the
hypotheses or the the questions that
Alex has laid a while ago that are the
geometric modes more passive onions than
the other anatomical modes and when I
say anatomical mods again we're focusing
on the connector modes which is based on
uh the connectivity Matrix but we also
test another anatomical mode based on
uh at EDR rule so an EDR rule is the
exponential distance rule which as Alex
has mentioned a while ago uh which is
that
because the Assumption of near field
theory is that the connections are very
localized and also uh organized in a
distance dependent way spec because
specifically the connection-wide changes
exponentially as a function of distance
so we want to test that uh hypothesis on
how dominant that exponential distance
effect
Ace set for the the
details we just created a synthetic
network based on a simple probability of
connection following an exponential
distance rule with a scaling factor or
an exponent in Alpha which we matched uh
from empirical diffusion MRI data and
again
there's a lot of uh empirical evidence
of the existence of this exponential
distance rule so it's not just a a
hypothetical theoretical
kind of assumption we see the effect in
mechanics if you follow the wet
as a function of distance from track
facing data and this is in uh
logarithmic scale you see this linear
curve which represents an exponential in
uh
linear you know coordinates and we see
the same with human uh diffusion MRI
data that the way changes as a function
of distance in an exponential distance
way and even in in other species like
Mouse rats marmosets and so on and so
forth so this is a universal property
found in a lot of different species so
this exponential distance through
connectivity
could be uh is actually uh
empirically valid
so by using these three different uh
anatomical properties we can calculate
the modes using the equations that
Alexis mentioned Omega and you can get
these geometric modes on the left
connector modes in Noodle and the modes
from the exponential distance through
connectivity on the right and again the
modes are arranged in quite a unique way
in that the first couple of modes will
represent the low spatial frequency or
patterns with very long special
wavelengths and if you go further down
you can get this high spatial frequency
or short spatial wavelength patterns so
it's a very uh so the basis set that the
modes provide
can capture different scales of the data
so how do these and anatomical modes
compare when we now reconstruct uh the
different uh FMI data that we have so
for resting state functional
connectivity
We compare the three modes Again by
measuring the accuracy as a function of
the number of modes and you can see that
the geometric mode outperform both of
the connector and the EDR mounts but you
can see that either amounts are quite uh
close to the geometric modes but so
again suggesting that the the
fundamental effect that the EDR
connectivity
uh
that's in in you know empirical data so
they like it it highlights the
importance of this simple but uh
important exponential distance through
connectivity and we can see the same
thing for by reconstructing the
different task activation maps that we
have again I'm showing you here the
difference so it's the geometric minus
the connector and geometric minor stedia
reconstruction accuracies and red means
the geometric modes are outperforming
the the other atomical modes so
in all the assets that we have the
results are quite consistent so again it
suggests that the geometric modes uh are
more passive values uh than the other
anatomical modes that we have
and then we we golf it bit further on
how do we actually use the concept of
these modes uh in analyzing uh
for my uh activation Maps
so I'll just kind of just want to
explain a little bit of what the
traditional approach we have in brain
map mapping research so for example you
do an experiment you
capture the activation map shown here
for a particular task and I'm showing
you here the kind of the 1B version of
that so the value of the activation
versus the the vertex in this cortical
surface so what traditionally what we do
is to uh
because we because we want to highlight
we want people ask okay if a person does
a particular task which regions of the
brain are kind of driving those
the
the behavioral performance that we had
when it was performing a particular task
so what people usually do is to
threshold these Maps uh and you can set
professional
barely arbitrarily uh and then you can
get these clusters of activity and we we
then make a conclusion that these
clusters of activity are the ones kind
of driving the behavioral uh effects
that we see whilst performing a task and
people can even go further and you know
hone down exactly really really highly
localized regions if you increase the
threshold
but if you go further back uh we started
from this whole brain activation map
you can clearly see that by thresholding
you're actually removing a lot of
important you know uh activity patents
uh that are sub threshold but they but
they do exist so it's kind of like uh
the analogy is you know it's by doing
this these uh thresholding approach you
just looking just at the tip of the
iceberg you're ignoring a lot of the
important properties of the iceberg that
are not seen by the threshold that you
sent
so what we can do is to use the mode
approach to actually look at uh
the uh and and kind of look at the
properties of all the of activation maps
and here on the left I'm showing you
here the power
of each mode so basically the whites
that we obtained from the
reconstructions that we had in a while
ago and
the figure on the left shows you the
results we have
on average for the human connecting
project data set and on the right is for
the 10 000 maps from your Evo
so what you can see here actually is
most of the power is already is
contained within about zero you know
about 50 modes and if you remember the
modes represent
and each mode represents a different
wavelength and they are arranged and at
the first couple of modes represent
these long spatial wavelength uh spatial
structure so what this means is that
actually in
in
FMI activation Maps
most of the power
is is within those long wavelengths kind
of suggesting that indeed by even by
performing a particular task you you are
actually activating these almost whole
brain uh
yeah yeah so you can see this almost
whole brain activity that again you will
miss out if you do some thresholding
effect and the further emphasize the
importance of these long wavelength
patterns we did a simple experiment
where we tried to remove say the first
couple uh long wavelength modes and
that's the solid curve that you see in
here and by doing so we start removing
those long wavelength modes we the
Reconstruction accuracy completely drops
even by just removing 25 of them but if
we just remove the you know the short
wavelength modes so starting from the
right the effect on the Reconstruction
accuracy is not that uh significant so
again alluding to the fact that these
long wave electrons are really important
uh and they describe uh the important
structure found in the activation maps
from FMI that
so again so we've shown how the modes
can explain and and represent spatial
activation patterns what happens with
the Dynamics
and the way we can do this is we go back
to the Crux of the neural field Theory
which were to be the geometric arguments
were based from and neurophy theory is
very generalized you can you know
construct different populations of
excitatory inhibition units and you can
even connect the thighs inside so forth
but the important bits to remember is
that very few theory that relies on the
idea that activation propagates through
space as waves
and to simplify the the
experiment that we want to do because we
want to model the activity as a function
of time
we just focus on the cortex and we
simulate the equation based from the
wave model and we should
the parameter but if you look at the
equation there's there are only two
parameters and we fix one of them so
basically the model is uh only relying
on tuning one free parameter
and what we did was to compare that with
uh a more sophisticated very Mass model
so there are mass models rely on the
connector so basically you have regions
in the brain that they are connected and
the connections are based from diffusion
MRI and each region will have its own
dynamical properties so they evolve
through through time so you realize a
lot of this on this connection and again
local Dynamics
but it's important to highlight that
this highly sophisticated model has
about 19 parameters and we fix about 15
of those but we still need to kind of
tune about four uh say in comparison to
the wave model again
model only has one and what we did was
to how well can it become recapitulate
uh functional connectivity uh data
so here I'm showing you an example uh
for the empirical functional
connectivity that we have and the
resulting model based functional
connectivity for both the wave and the
mirror Mass models
and we can uh kind of
quantify how well the the model based
functional connectivity
results uh stack up with respect to the
empirical data in a in a variety of ways
one can look at how well
that's the edge FC so basically each
element of this Matrix
Compares between the empirical and the
model based data and you can see that
both models are you know performing
quite similarly
we can also look at the average
connectivity within each region so
basically you're taking the average of a
row or a column and you can see that the
wave model now outperforms the mirror
Mass model by a bit
and you can gain further because these
properties the first two properties are
based on static FC basically you you're
kind of averaging the effects across
time but we also mentioned our two
models compare in capturing uh
dynamical properties full time and you
see that the way model actually
performs uh the neural Mass model
and so in summary for this it's just to
show that the Simplicity of the wave
model uh
can capture a lot of these properties of
functional data again highlighting the
the idea that these wave
evolving or traveling in in space and
time in the brain is probably a good
approximation
we also simulated uh the effect if we
stimulate say the visual cortex so we
just ping these beautiful cortex and
allow it to the activity to propagate uh
through space and time and this will be
the propagation starts from the physical
cortex and then it goes to the frontal
uh
uh cortex and I think I want to
highlight one observation that we found
is that
we can see that when we started from
division Politics the activity starts to
separate into two and in the psychology
and your science literature
people operate have actually found this
effect and they call it the separation
into the dorsal and ventral stream and
each stream has important uh cognitive
implications
but people have uh tried to explain the
Separation by capturing the complex
layer specific activity in the video
quartix but what this simple experiment
that we have done has shown that maybe
the geometry and the idea of waves
propagating
could be sufficient in uh obtaining
these uh kind of physiological effect
um and then we also tried to compare it
with how well does it we capitulate the
visual hierarchy that people have found
in primates for for example this work by
uh
uh in the last uh
a couple of years where they uh also did
a simulation uh where they stimulated
the the cortex and what they found was
if you followed regions along the visual
hierarchy in the macaque cortex you see
the activity patterns are kind of
delayed in a hierarchical way so they
follow the same kind of uh
relationship as the visual hierarchy so
we did the same thing we compared the
activity the Ambit should
of the activity by matching the regions
that people found individual hierarchy
of the macarthics and we we tried to
find the regions in the human brain
and then we see the same effect and then
we when we compared it to a typical
measure of hierarchy in the new Imaging
Space by using the intercortical map
which is just the ratio of T1 and T2
we see the affected the time to peak of
these activation patterns
uh what captures the rack of the
infracorical Marine again highlighting
that indeed what we're getting is
capturing this this hierarchical kind of
processing uh
uh starting from Individual cortex
and think of the last result that I want
to highlight is the uh
the subcortex because
again the brain is just not it's not
just the cortex so what we did was to
also calculate the modes from
subcortical regions and what we did was
to mask the subcortical regions and
perform the same uh and and uh
solve the same equation using the
LaPlace with primary operator and you
can get these Arguments for the thymus
spray item in the hippocampus and we
compared that to what we call in the
field as functional gradients basically
they are representations uh low
dimensional representation of resting
state FMI data so
what we did was to
compare the geometric modes for the
different subcortical structures and the
different functional gradients based on
FMI data and you can see that the modes
uh
almost perfect in perfect correspondence
with the functional gradients and we see
the same effect for the different
structures again probably highlighting
the idea that the geometric effects that
we solve in the cortex are much more
dominant in the subcortics that geometry
really constraints function
um
just to tie things together
what are the advantages of this approach
that we found
first it's a it's a more physical
understanding of the relationship
between structure and function based on
ideas in physics engineering that has
been used in the last century
the convection modes are only based on
T1 rated images so it's very simple to
perform and the analysis can be done by
anyone with a structural T1 weighted
image and hence you can apply it in
quite different experimental contexts in
both humans other species health and
disease
and finally to summarize things
I hopefully we've shown that drastic
modes are indeed more passive monies
than other anatomical modes and this is
confirming a lot of the predictions from
theoretical uh
calculations of near field Theory and
highlights the importance of treating
the brain as this uh really physical
system in correspondence with what we
people are doing in physics and
engineering
uh but it also highlights the idea that
the effects that we see in FMI might be
dominated by the effect of this simple
local and exponential distance for
connectivity however uh
the the uh the contributions of
long-range connections are still there
but the
uh what we're highlighting is maybe the
uh
their influence may not be observable
with the resolution that we currently
have with FMI data so it would be
interesting to see and perform these
experiments in a much more highly
resolved say track tracing data from
other species
uh that we found that evoked activity is
dominated by these long wavelength nodes
which is pretty much challenges a lot of
the traditional approach that we have in
the new Imaging field where we focus a
lot on these focal activations
and that traveling waves shaped by
geometry are sufficient to explain a lot
of a lot of physiological phenomena by
you know that they just emerge from the
model and within begged all these
physiological phenomena into the model
uh and finally the geometric constraints
seem to be universally uh exist in both
cortex and subcortics and that we can
only we can use one single approach to
study the you know the whole brain uh
quite nicely
and I just wanna
both Alex and I would like to thank all
the other co-authors of the work he has
been a truly multi-institute
collaboration
all the Open Access Data set that we
have used and if people are interested
in doing our analyzes
we have written an Open Access uh
software package repository in GitHub
you can access that in here so people
can you know
analyze valves in the brain in quite
different contexts that they want to do
and I think that's where we want to end
thank you
awesome well thank you for the great
presentation
a lot of places to go first all past to
Dean
um thank you gentlemen I I
I first got winded this paper through uh
another individual on the active
inference community
and I think I was the one that may have
pounded the table that we might want to
do a a guest stream on this and it's
picked the paper and really brought it
to life so
thank you very much I really appreciate
it especially some of the dynamic images
I think it really helps in terms of
explaining what you guys were trying to
um
trying to do your work with in your and
your subject matter on so I'll just
start with that I have some questions
later on but just first of all thank you
for uh
for a fantastic
um explanation
thank you
well you present this in a neuroscience
setting what's a common response or
reaction from the introduction
I could really tell how careful you were
to
speak to the totality and the different
threads in Neuroscience so after all
that set up and all the statistical
analysis that's presented
where does that put people in terms of
their own understanding of the way that
they've been doing
complementary methodologies or orienting
their research questions that way
yeah I think um
and generally people I mean at least we
found that people are quite interested
um I guess the approach is a bit
different to how a neuroscientist would
typically think about the brain but kind
of aligns with how say you know a
physicist might now Lively start
approaching thinking about a modeling
the brain and so the work was really
trying to bring those two kind of
perspectives together
um you know I think the other reaction
is is usually kind of yeah this is this
is really interesting
um you know then
how do I how do I make sense of it or
what I do practically
um you know there has been
I guess
there is
some people might kind of split
split it artificially into this
comparison of odd geometry versus
connectivity
um which is probably not the right way
to think about it
um it's you know the way we like to
think about it is that
um you know we're sort of comparing two
different models and each of those
models makes certain approximations and
prioritizes different features
um
the you know the approach we put forward
in this paper emphasizes the role of
geometry and it does have connectivity
embedded in that model it's just a kind
of simplified approximation of
connectivity this kind of homogeneous
distance dependent panel
um whereas you know typical connectome
Centric view will try to capture all the
complex connectivity but we'll ignore
also the horizontal connectivity
um that really is what drives activity
spreading through the brain that's
completely ignored and so really you
know the idea behind this work was to
kind of test in a way between these two
approaches and you know say which ones
approximations were kind of more useful
in a sense
do you want to add something or I can
make a comment there
no finish finish this because then I'm
going to ask my questions about the
cello yeah well the statistics was very
clear and and it was very interesting
how with two different data sets there
was similar curves with also very
different number of samples
so it was almost like the the some of
the statistical distributions were
latched onto relatively early
and then that like captured the big
continent and um
a lot of the connections are local this
is and this is of course a topic to
explore about the molecular and the
mechanistic electromagnetic basis and
whether this to what extent it
represents traveling propagating
electrochemical waves
and or loading heavily on simply
diffuse local connections and and even
the the blurry line between those two
so it is really like a question about
what is being captured because even the
EDR with the spread
captures a variance component related to
local abundance direct fast acting
connections
in some regions and distance connections
maybe over the days
digital connections really do matter as
as the the jello sets
and things change
but at the exact time scale that some of
these patterns are happening at your
work is showing new
information
and comparison with different ways it's
been looked at
yeah
um I mean
I think one of the
things that it highlighted or even
probably just you know in my head is
we've been focusing a lot on
trying to capture the effects of this
complex connectivity right and we ignore
all these lateral horizontal local you
know diffusing connections
but what the work has now kind of shown
it highlighted the kind of maybe the
issues that we have with FMI right maybe
you know
because truly the both of these roles
happen
probably you know simultaneously right
but just the effects that we're seeing
in FMI
but it's probably not the most efficient
way to capture Both Worlds uh or it
cannot hung down the specifics of one
world over the other
uh
in the resource that we're getting is
the the effects of this you know very
localized connectivity
probably dominates uh a lot of what we
see there FMI uh but
time will tell if you know we improve
the ways we capture right activated with
openai and this is really kind of
particularly focused on the different
aspects of the approximations
uh to me that's the kind of the beauty
of the work it now highlighted these
effects
into the you know broader audience
yeah I think that definitely I mean you
know everything that we've presented is
really addressing things that we measure
with fmri so on pretty course spatial
and temporal scales there's some
theoretical work suggesting that kind of
you know the more complex aspects of
connectivity that can't be explained by
an EDR I play an important role in
supporting Dynamic transitions between
different brain States
um but that would happen on a very rapid
scale that could be missed with fmri at
least a typically organized fmri
experiment and so one thing we're
interested in in looking at further is
trying to pick that apart a little bit
and trying to isolate the functional
contributions of those more complicated
connections
okay
cool Dean
can I ask about the metaphor of the the
spoon tapping on the on the cello there
metaphorically speaking that seems like
it's like an external perturbation on a
on something that can respond to that
now
he'll appreciate I'm I'm asking from a
very naive point of view and
uncomfortable with it is there any
difference then in in terms of say
something that happens
interceptively like something that's
simply coming from within system and
does that does that show up in the same
way as when there's a response to an
external stimuli
yeah so you know the actual underlying
model a key component that we haven't
really talked about is that you have uh
thalamo cortical loops and there's a
driving input from the thalamus that
influences the wave activity in the
cortex
and uh you know they could be sensory
thalamic nuclei or they could be
interceptive inputs as well and they are
would be expected to drive cortical
activity in different and you know
spatially non-uniform ways
um you know really distinguishing
between those different types of inputs
as far as I'm aware hasn't been modeled
yet it's all been kind of a a simple
level where you treat the cortex
homogeneously and you have a single
thalamic nucleus I mean some people have
started to split them up
um but you know that would be that the
underlying principle and the model could
be extended
um in such a way that you could
potentially distinguish between
interceptive and extra receptive inputs
I just want to add for example the
visual cortex experiment that we perform
it's a really simple perturbation right
but it could represent different types
of perturbation and we just can't you
know particularly capture at the moment
but it's like an overlying if we perturb
it in a certain way this will be the
effect that we see uh but yeah you might
want to know what I was going to ask
next thing because that was the
direction I was going with that visual
cortex example so
so from the active infants Community one
of the things that we're always dealing
with is surprise
say versus sensory attenuation and then
on the third vertices the
seeming unawareness prior to the
surprise or the attenuated state but
still available and so I'm kind of
curious
when you move away from the visual
can you still have these sort of same
waves going through the brain because
other sensory uptake is causing that
same you get a surprise in feeling like
a sense of weightlessness perhaps right
or your your an astronaut and
that's now something new you become
attenuated to what
is there I know it kind of stuck with
the fmri but it just seems so the
possibilities in terms of what you guys
are opening up
just seems really interesting is that
something
like the Interceptor thing where you can
see this now having
opening up new new areas of inquiry
uh yeah so I think there's some really
interesting work
where
[Music]
um
people have looked at
um recursive neural Nets
uh structured in such a way that you can
get wave-like propagation between the
elements of the network and have shown
that the systems that have that wave
like propagation uh it actually
facilitates their ability to predict
what's happening in same movie
um so it improves their predictive
performance uh physiologically it'll
have shown that you know just with
simple visual stimulation you get these
back to front propagations but there's
also front
to back propagations which are
presumably encoding the predictions and
so then the question is
how do the
top down predictions in the bottom-up
censoring will get reconciled between
the interactions of these waves
um you know I think these are kind of
really interesting ways forward that
we're still coming to terms with and
we're not we haven't really quite
[Music]
um
made sense of what the what the wires
mean for computation I know that Peter
Robinson who's on the slide here has
written a couple of papers
um talking about how these fields can
relate to predictions
um yeah but yeah I think this is kind of
a
very new exciting area that um is worth
exploring
yeah one kind of connection there is
like the standing wave that you showed
in the physical water pool
and so now when we're looking at a solid
color visually
there's some St and there's some stable
non-equilibrium steady state or stable
representation or a stable population
code or all these different things which
which may not be
um
exhaustive or incompatible like at all
but there's some standing wave now maybe
that is
component number 99 just like principle
component 99 it's amplitude might be
small
but there's like some
mode
that is that's ramping up and its
Associated positively or it's ramping
down its Associated negatively
and and there's some
standing pattern that emits the pelting
of new sensory observations and like a
Bayesian updating setting
it is remaining the same now the more
inertia you have on the distribution the
more stable it's going to be which is
like equivalent to saying the less
attention you pay to sensory stimuli the
more stable your your priors are going
to be it could be a prior about
perception it could be a prior about
action
and there are descending motor
patterns as well and all these different
modes are being played like
in an apartment building and there's
like different songs but they're
happening in different frequency spatial
temporal and frequency bands so that we
can tune in to different songs like
different radio stations
but with more spatial richness
it's a total expansion of the palette
that
recapitulates certain aspects of
topology and helps us even identify
residuals that are are most apt to be
explained
that way
but it also opens up to like these big
waves that get filtered out like by low
pass potentially filtering in different
data sets
so that shorter term relationships can
become more apparent
but that can be the Ripple on the wave
and so end up throwing out a huge amount
just of the sheer information contents
of Rich dynamical data sets
yeah really interesting concept trying
to wrap my hair around it
uh yes it's it's really cool because you
know again
we we still don't know what because what
we found is that for example in a
different task data that we have not all
modes are equally excited certain modes
are excited in quite different ways and
we don't know what yet what these
combinations mean truly uh behaviorally
cognitively and
but yeah we'll we'll keep working on it
as far as and
see what happens yeah
tell us one more quick question so so I
appreciate the geometry part of it
um
so
does any of this
speak also to the the sort of the
tunneling effects of the sort of that
eigen value or eigen mode eigenvalue
Quantum peace where
it's you know you could be rotting the
surface of this and appreciating that
the the parsimonious speaking
speak to that surface effect
is there anything about this that also
helps us understand better how something
goes you know from through the wave like
quite literally across from one one
slope past the crown and on to the other
side or is that again something that you
guys weren't really spending a lot of
time on but I did notice I I pulled out
the paper and I noticed on page 11 you
were talking about some of the ways that
you were analyzing the volumes so that's
the context that I was curious about
that sort of tunneling piece to go along
with how we sort of follow the the
patterns on the surface
well I'm not quite sure I follow you
asking how
let me try to let me try to see where it
comes as I see it Dean's a Quantum
tunneling connoisseur
most even
and uh with the basis set of the sine
wave
it's like imposing this kind of
oscillatory pattern and then you're
you're up waiting or down waiting but is
it possible to use a basis set or is it
possible to detect modes in your
analysis where there's like an effect
locally and then there's like a then
there's like a tunnel and there's like a
region that the wave doesn't appear to
pass through
oh
by the way thank you Daniel
oh we're stumped I guess it means on
what you mean by tunneling right so like
each mode like if you look at the high
frequency modes they are quite patchy
and so they'll be sort of disjointed
areas of high amplitude and low
amplitude but they fluctuate in time
right like then there's standing waves
and so they'll kind of alternate up and
down so in a sense it looks like there's
coupling over long distances
um
but
um that's just due to the standing wide
dynamics which is just driven by the
interference pattern of the traveling
rights
um so you know I'm not sure if that's
kind of what you're getting at but I
guess yeah from a perspective of just if
you're just looking at the standing wave
Dynamics it would look like things in
spatially disjoint locations were kind
of uh coupled in some way okay
it's like one jello
it it stays put where you hit it and it
stays put
one mile away
and it oscillates between like a jump
rope
um or it could be hit somewhere that's
also very variable then be like the
opposite of a jump rope
with one one mode
and that's what's captured in the set of
functions that are then parameterized so
then when you assemble them or when you
um superimpose them you you could get
like
um
kind of digitized looking
outcome patterns in terms of the real
empirical correlations
and it's map not territory and it's
tempting to interpret these very
literally as with many statistical tools
one I think as we've discussed like
there's there's multiple possible
mechanisms and in your paper and in your
work you probably
thought of many many
chanisms that lend themselves to like
unique empirical predictions
but
basis set decomposition is used like in
SPM
which is kind of like the
one of the precedents of active
inference and and the work by Carl first
and others it's using basis sets as well
so
yeah they used uh they use it everywhere
do you have any closing
or or near closing like thoughts or
where does the work go
how do people what data sets are Salient
or questions or cognitive phenomena or
like what are you excited about for your
lab and for the fields
your left
I mean there's there's a few different
uh ways that we're interested in in
progressing it um
so one is I guess trying to reconcile
this uh purely geometric approach that
makes a very simple approximation with
connectivity with the actual
connectivity of the brain and trying to
understand
if
the contributions of these kind of
complex connections are not so easily
revealed by classic fmri experiment or
what are their contributions to Dynamics
and is there a way of kind of uh
bringing some of that complex
connectivity into the into the wave
model and trying to get some traction on
that question
um
another aspect is
you know we've done the simplest thing
we trade all areas of the cortex is
homogeneous but we know that's not the
case uh areas vary in terms of the cell
density degree of myelination and level
of synaptic complexity and density and
so on
um and so that in a sense could be
imagine you could imagine that it's
changing the effective geometry of the
cortex and so we're playing around with
how do you introduce that heterogeneity
and how does that change the mode
structure and uh does that have an
impact on your ability to reconstruct
Dynamics
um
we're then also interested in sort of
taking this board to
leverage these approaches for thinking
about different ways in which we might
be able to map brain changes in
different disorders or or variations
across species and so on and so kind of
like um
you know classical SPM analyzes but
making inference at the modal level and
seeing if that can provide some some
useful insights
so there's a few different
strategies
any other comments or thoughts
yeah Dean where where do you go after
this Dean in your own neuroimaging
career
no stop it I just think it was a very
clear picture and I really again I
really appreciated the paper itself
um but today's presentation sort of
brought it to life and made it a lot
I know that you guys are really trying
to focus on making sure that you got all
of your your uh
all your formalities in in a row but
just the way you presented it today made
it a lot it made it even more come alive
in terms of the the
the mechanisms that you use to sort of
come up with
with a clearer picture but that's what I
came in with away with so again thank
you very much
yeah thank you thank God we'll look
forward to seeing the continuation of
this trajectory you're always welcome
back so thank you both
thank you thanks guys see ya bye
thank you